let's go with the science fellow uh he
uh he said the other days um
he criticized my
uh theory and he was looking at the word
hypothesis he was saying
that
hypothesis need to be tested okay let's
listen to his own words okay they can
come out of his own mouth so i'm gonna
set this in motion here give me a second
here goes
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal are
what is a hypothesis
and
is a hypothesis testable
you need to be able to formulate a
hypothesis and that hypothesis needs to
be testable and then you have to test
that hypothesis
okay so you're saying uh we have to test
the hypothesis
how do you test the hypothesis well
before we can test it we have to figure
out what a hypothesis is then maybe we
can decide how we're going to test it
with an experiment i mean i don't know
let's find out let's find out what a
hypothesis is first okay and so we look
at the word we look it up and we find
all these versions here that it's a
purpose a question a tentative guess
punch uh
talking about a prediction also it's an
assumption an explanation
uh you present evidence for him so you
can test it i guess right it's a theory
a provisional explanation
a tentative theory you know uh you know
another file says data analysis
i mean are all these synonyms that
hypothesis is everything
what the hell is a hypothesis i mean you
know uh here i um
summarize it for you okay
uh will the real hypothesis please stand
up okay because they have all these
versions of what a hypothesis is you
know i think they lost track of what
they're talking about after a while okay
and so the question is you know is a
hypothesis the same thing as a purpose
and if it's a purpose is it the same
thing as a prediction
if it's not a prediction you know then
uh
what is it what are we talking about
here you know
we got a real problem here because you
know they have all these versions of
what a hypothesis is
okay
is a is an assumption the same thing as
an explanation is a
question the same thing as a tentative
guess
i mean you know they have all these
versions you know what is a hypothesis
and i i can tell you right now
mathematics has no idea what a
hypothesis is
they have so many versions of it that
people have lost track of what a
hypothesis is but uh most people define
it as this and these are definitions
you'll find out there okay most of them
essentially say that it's a um tentative
explanation this is more or less where
most people converge upon when they
officially or you know define the word
hypothesis and there you see all the
versions okay
okay so is that what um what a
hypothesis is
is uh
you know just all these uh
versions of explanations possible
explanations or proposed explanations et
cetera well when you do a scientific uh
dictionary there britannica you know it
says uh hypothesis differs fundamentally
from theories
my god uh they're saying it's a theory
over here on the left and on the right
they're saying oh by the way you know
it's different okay let's see what's
different about them it says whereas the
former is a specific tentative
explanation serves as the main tool by
which scientists gather data the latter
is a broad general explanation that
incorporates data from many different
scientific investigations
so i guess what they're saying here is
that uh in one case it's an explanation
from one fella or collector from
information or data that he collected in
his basement and uh the other
explanation the theory that's from many
basements
great i mean is this the difference one
basement versus many basements is that
what uh the difference between a
hypothesis and a theory
okay so we have a problem there um and
then to top it off we have this fellow
and uh
no got the wrong way hold it i have this
cell here and uh he's from the
university he's an emeritus professor
and his name is donald simone and says
science doesn't explain
science describes
because that's what math can do that's
the only thing math can do describe
and so science doesn't explain you know
we started out saying well what is a
hypothesis it's an explanation a
tentative explanation they have all
these versions actually you know it's a
it's a prediction it's a uh an
assumption it's a data collection who
knows what else then they say well no no
it's it's an explanation different kinds
of explanation but it's an explanation
great and now they say well there's a
difference between explanation and
hypothesis one hypothesis when one guy
has explanation what many people have
apparently that's what it's all about
one versus many now this guy said oh by
the way we don't explain anything
so we went full circle what did you
learn today in school son not much but
not much
okay so we don't know what a hypothesis
is but if it's an explanation as well
says we don't explain so at this point i
don't know what science is about if
science is about explaining or about
testing hypotheses and uh and hypothesis
explanation and we don't explain right
okay okay but let's assume that it's an
explanation and this file says we're
gonna test that we should test the
hypothesis okay let's test it let's see
how we're going to test it and here's an
example this is a
general relativity gravity under general
relativity okay and these are
confirmations of the explanations for
gravity according to you know general
relativity these are things that they
claim they confirmed through experiments
okay so general relativity they say is
the most confirmed theory out there you
know and it's confirmed by all these
experiments
okay let's
let's find out let's
uh listen to what these people have to
say so here's the first one okay
mercury's perihelion shift okay and it's
what you find out there it says
mercury's very healing shift einstein's
1915 general theory accounted for
mercury's anomalous recession einstein
wrote to michael basil barry helion
explain quantitatively
you will be astonished yeah i'm already
astonished because i don't know how you
can explain quantitatively you know what
does that mean you either explain or you
describe quantitative is only
descriptions so i guess uh einstein
didn't understand the difference between
an explanation of description either
okay
and then in general relativity this
change of orientation of the orbital
ellipse within its orbital plane is
explained by gravitation being mediated
by what the curvature of time
the curvature of time there you see a
warp time
so they're explaining the orbit of uh
mercury by saying that time has
curvature time has been warmed time is
bent
as this all said the other day
um is this what it's all about saying
that uh is this does this sound rational
to you to say that time is bent time is
work that explains why mercury rolls
around in these ellipses shifting
ellipses
i mean does this make any sense how did
how did they confirm that
uh observation experiment i'm you know
uh testing the hypothesis that's how
they did it
let's move on light bending
gravitational lensing this is another
confirmation of relativity let's see how
they did this one this got to be fun
okay here it is okay light bending the
bending of light is in gravitational
fields all this from um from the
wikipedia by the way experiments showing
light bending in accordance with the
predictions of general relativity were
performed in 1919 okay i don't know what
experiment they could have done or what
predictions these were but how do you
bend light einstein became the first to
calculate the correct value of light
bending and as after newton you know
gravity predicts that starlight will
bend around a massive object so how do
you bend uh a wave transverse wave
uh assuming that's what you know because
they're saying that these uh gravity
they talk about gravitational waves so
how do you bend these waves and how do
you bend photons assuming you know
photons are the same thing as gravitons
or vice versa and you have all these
particles it could be either photons
gravitons or any particle muons if you
want i mean or higgs
you know how do you bend these things if
we're talking about particles or waves
how do you bend them
okay so so again i don't know how they
proved this they say these are the
confirmations that they prove that
through experiments how do you prove
that you're going to bend light how do
you prove that you bend gravity how are
you going to prove that you bend
magnetism
what sense does any of that make how do
you do that how do you test the
hypothesis
okay uh they do space bending okay let's
find out what that's all about space
bending that's got to be fun here it is
uh
if you want anything bent you should
call on i need service okay he he bends
anything he bends bananas hammocks
whatever you got yeah here's his
einstein theory suggested that large
objects bend the space around them
okay i don't know how you can bend space
if it's not a physical object but this
is the way they treat it massive
celestial bodies like the earth drag
their local space time around with them
as they rotate that comes out of nasa
okay how do gravity probe be uh
experiment by the way and so the
question is how does the earth drag a
concept such as time around
you know what sense does this mean how
did they prove that and he said well
they sent some gyroscopes there and they
moved
okay so the gyroscopes moved and
so they inferred
they didn't prove anything they inferred
that uh the gyroscopes moved oscillated
or whatever moved out of their position
because they rubbed their elbows against
space
how did they do that
no they made an assumption that space is
a physical object and the gyroscope
rubbed its you know elbow against the uh
this thing called space
or time maybe maybe you know it was
against time that it described its elbow
i mean what sense does it
make to say that they confirmed
experimentally that earth drags time
around itself
what is this this is nonsense or space
it doesn't really matter
okay how about uh time bending time oh
man that's got to be just as good okay
here it is and you know he he bends the
seconds good old line either strong men
on e that's gravity bend time in quora
the answer says if i answer he says if
you consider time and space to be the
same thing then yes and that's what
hawking told us he says in relativity
there is no real distinction between the
space and time coordinates okay and then
in a stack exchange another prominent
site who supposedly does at least
mathematical physics okay gravity is the
bending of time
yeah these people spend time how did
they confirm all this how did they test
this hypothesis when you cannot even
make sense of it i mean before you do an
experiment hopefully you do a design of
experiment and this fellow is saying
don't test the hypothesis how do you
test a hypothesis such as that you're
going to bend time or you're going to
bend space or you're going to warp the
field or or bendy or you know curve the
um wave or a series of gravitons or
photons particles how do you do this
what conformations are how do you test
the hypothesis please give me a
mechanism how you test the hypothesis
and we're going to find out whether you
uh did anything physical whether you
explained anything rationally okay
that's that's the issue so now we don't
test hypothesis whatever that means
okay um
why haven't these people zeroed in you
know the mathematicians mathematicians
mathematics why haven't they
ever figured out gravity
well they have figured out not only
gravity but any of the invisible
intangible
uh
uh phenomena out there you know you you
have gravity you have magnetism you have
electricity the atom you can't see in
there it's so tiny or
simply up you know like in the case of
magnetism i always show this two magnets
right the two little circles there and
uh you can see that there's there's
absolutely nothing between them okay
nothing that you can touch or see and
you can just do this at home i mean you
don't have to believe what i'm saying
i'm just saying put your hand between
two magnets you won't feel or see
anything
okay so how do you test that
do you go to the lab and do what please
tell me what experiment you can think of
in which you're going to detect what
magnetism is what that invisible
mediator looks like that's what we're
trying to find out
and uh so here let me show you uh a
couple of things here that you can see
what the problem was for the last 2500
years why they haven't figured any of
this out here you see a chariot okay
fellow charioteer and he's uh
he's got his horse
tied to
his buggy there okay his little chariot
and so we understand it we look and we
say well why does the chariot move
uh together with a horse and you say
well because somehow the horses the
horse is bound to the chariot or the
chariot bound to the horse they're in
physical contact that's why this is not
surprising that we're used to these
kinds of things every day you know and
we look at this and we say okay i
understand it i don't need to go to
college to understand why the cart moved
there okay
okay so uh here let's look at it again
now here's this situation
okay
and now you say well why is the cart
moving now whoa that's scary i mean you
know how is it that the horse is pulling
on the cart assuming that's what's
happening right maybe something's
pushing on the cart from behind but we
don't see anything in front or behind
the cart
so why is the cart moving together with
a horse
and so people have problems here because
they say oh man this is this is weird
this is out of this world i can't see
your touch
if you were there right uh you know
whatever's the bomb between the horse
and the charioteer there or the chariot
right you know you can't see uh what's
connecting them and so this is when it
becomes really scary so let's look at it
again side by side okay or up and down
okay
on the top you have um
the one that's connected and on the
bottom you have one that's not connected
and the top one we have no problem
understanding and accepting the problem
we have is with the bottom one okay and
so this is the issue the issue is the
only reason you cannot explain gravity
the only reason you cannot explain
magnetism is you cannot see the
invisible things
that um are mediating between two
magnets or between the earth and the
spoon in case of the spoon falling to
earth
gravity
and so
and all you have to do is do what you
see here you once you make the reins you
know and so on the uh thing that's
connecting the horse to the
buggy there uh once you make that
visible then it's not a mystery it's
kid's stuff you don't need math you
don't need to go to college you can just
look and say okay i can explain that
it's tied you know that's why the card's
moving the only reason you would not be
able to is if you have the bottom
situation where you don't have
a connection between the horse and the
charioteer okay so this is the issue the
issue is that
the only reason these people have been
stumped throughout history of why the
spoon falls to earth is because they
can't see or touch the mediators why
have they they've been stumped by
magnetism you know because they can't
see or touch the mediators
if you make the mediators visible and
show a mechanism of how it's done now
people say
that's kid stuff anybody can understand
that
the only reason is you can't see the
mediators period we're done okay so
there's nothing to test what are you
going to test as far as
something that is invisible or
intangible i mean this individual says
go and test the hypothesis okay we go to
the lab what do you want me to do
how am i supposed to test the hypothesis
here okay
what am i supposed to do please tell me
how you would test the hypothesis the
hypothesis is what that particles what
was it green pixies attract these two
things great show me in the lab
uh or wherever you want to test it i
mean i don't know show me how a magnet
attracts another or how a pencil you
know falls to earth
okay
uh with pixie whatever you want
particles waves
show me the mechanism test the
hypothesis all you want then come back
and tell me this is what the mechanism
is tell me how it was done how the magic
trick was done that's what we want to
understand okay
yeah so these are my conclusions okay
hypothesis is not a theory
it's not a theory hypothesis is
an assumption an assumption is not an
explanation which is what a theory is
okay
and uh description is not an explanation
and i talked about that in the past i'll
be talking about more of that in the
future but right now i'm not going to
get into that but now anyone who thinks
that an explanation is a series of
descriptions well he's got something
else coming and he should go to square
number one what was it the idiot honor
roll there and find out if uh if a
description is the same thing as a uh
explanation
okay explanation what is it it's a
mechanism you have to explain the cause
okay you what is explanation in physics
right it's a physical interpretation
what caused something to happen it's not
how in the sense of let me describe it
for you no it's how
in the sense of let me explain it how it
worked what caused it to happen that's
what a mechanism that's what a mechanism
is and that's what physics is about
explaining the mechanism that's known as
a physical interpretation but even
assuming we concede to this one say okay
you're going to test the hypothesis fine
and what is a hypothesis well i guess
he's going to say it's an explanation of
some kind a tentative one whatever i
don't care but it's an explanation one
way or another i don't care what
adjective you put in front or adverb
okay fine so the first issue is
verification assuming we go in there and
we falsify we test we verify
all you did was believe you changed
someone's belief
okay you just changed his opinion
you haven't
done any more than that you just gave
them your opinion your version you say i
i tested the hypothesis okay you tested
it great
what did you come up with well i came up
with this
and what you're telling about is i want
you to believe in my theory
i want you to believe in my hypothesis
in in the way i explain this
and the guy says yeah this guy believes
in this guy doesn't so all you did was
affect belief
science is not belief so we don't test
hypothesis even if a hypothesis is an
explanation and even if you tested it
you know all you did was try to convince
something of your version of events
that's all you did okay and then you
know with all these uh tests experiments
did he came up come up with they came up
with irrational explanations physical
interpretations for the ones that i just
mentioned you know uh gravity uh
primarily uh in this case you know and
uh
what have they done they have what have
they explained by saying space-time is
work is that a rational explanation so
here they tested the hypothesis it went
out there they did the experiment they
say we confirmed
uh that the hypothesis was tested that
it was verified i don't know what the
language is in mathematics okay so you
did all that what did you come up with
well they came up with warped time
that's gravity warp time great
seconds are warped the minutes are
worked the years are worth
what kind of explanation is that it's
irrational totally so they're testing
all their experiments only led them to
irrational irrational explanation to
irrationalities
okay and uh you can't test
you know if you're going to test the
explanation you can't test what is
invisible
and intangible you know uh magnetism
gravity you can't test that
uh all you can do is make an assumption
of what you think is in there what
physical object is mediating the
transaction and based on that assumption
you give an explanation so that someone
understands the mechanism okay that we
can all follow
but uh other than that you know uh what
are you gonna test what experiment
you're gonna run uh for this again
here's the experiment this is the only
experiment you need for gravity you let
go of the pencil and it falls down
okay here on earth
okay so it falls downwards great
that's the only experiment you you did
you did the experiment now come back and
tell us why
that's what you got to do but to say
that you did the experiment i let go of
the pen a million times to make it very
you know a repeatable verifiable yeah so
i measured i know the speed great and
any any uh what idiot can do that no we
want a scientist we want someone who can
explain what caused the pencil to fall
downwards
and
no so we don't need to test the
hypothesis what we do in science we
visualize we attempt to visualize the
mechanism and for that you know all you
need to have is maybe a beer on your
right hand you're left-handed you can
use your left i guess
and visualize you know try to imagine
how mother nature could be doing these
magic tricks i mean how would you do it
if you go and see watch a magician on
stage he cuts the lady in half or does
something with balloons and uh and um
you know dubs you know takes a
handkerchief maybe a dove comes out
makes a magic trick
and you say oh man how did he do that
and okay and so you try to figure out
how he did it that's how you do it what
are you going to go there with a
measuring run say let me measure this
okay i'm gonna measure the hanky that
you use i'm gonna measure the dove see
if he fits in there and i mean you know
no the way you do it you sit down there
with the audience you try to visualize
how the guy could have done the trick
and that's how that's how science works
that's how physics works you have to try
to figure out how the universe works as
an as a spectator the only way you can
do that for invisible intangible things
is
visualizing
you